ﾊﾟｼｯﾊﾟｼｯﾊﾟｼｯ
ｼｬ…ｼｬﾙﾛｯﾄ……
こんにちわ♡
ﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯﾊﾟﾝｯ
あああああああああああっ！！！！
実は、筋トレがしたいと思っています。
はじめしゃちょーです
はいっ、というわけでいよいよ8月に入りました皆様、いかがお過ごしでしょうか。
今回はまぁ、お知らせという感じですね。
動画のタイトルを見たら多分分かると思うんですけども、
実はですね、ちょっと大切なお話しがありまして
僕の生活に関するお話しでございます。
昨日かな、8月の、ちょうど8月の一日
8月に入ってから僕実は、この家…あの、一人で住んでません。
一人では住んでないです。えーと、実はですね…
去年かな…去年からだ…去年の夏から一年間ぐらい実は…あの…内緒で……
ずっと付き合ってる彼女がいま…せん。
ﾌﾞｩｯ！！！！！
彼女なんているわけねぇだろ！！
はいという冗談これぐらいにしまして、まぁでも実はタイトルにある通りでございます。
実はっ！わたくし、はじめしゃちょー…8月から！ある人と…この家で！共同生活をすることが決まりました！！
ありがとーーーございます！！
誰かというとちょっと今から…呼ぶか！
呼んだ方が早いな！ちょっと呼んできましょう！
おーーーーーい！！おーーーい！！聞こえるかーー！！！もしもーーーし！！！
………こ○す
なんしとん？
ばれたか。
ははっ
めっちゃ叫んどったやん
ﾊﾟｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｱｱｱｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧﾝﾝ!!!!!!
ノーリアクションか～い
8月からわたくしの家に住むことになりました。弟ですどうぞ
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
というわけで、ちょっと一か月間弟がしばらく私の家に住みます。
いや、マジでありがたい
ホントに？それはそれで俺も助かるんだけどね
動画にいつもいますというわけじゃなくて、ただホントに住んでるだけっていう感じなので、とくに深い意味はありません。
帰っていいぞ
ありがとう
はい、というわけで、この静岡のほうでは弟がしばらくこの家にずっといます。
なぜ僕の家に住むかっていう理由なんですけども、実はアイツ9月から留学に行くことが決まりまして、
ただいま大学にアイツ行ってるんですけど、大学の夏休み前のテストが終わって大学～
尿
大学の一人暮らしする部屋を引き払って、お金がもったいないから引き払って僕ん家に来てると、
なのでその留学に行くまでの8月の間は一か月間だけなんですけど僕の家にアイツがずっといます
これによってこのはじめしゃちょーのなにが変わるかといいますと、あの～実はかなり助かります。
あのですねぇ、まぁ、忙しいというか、こう～時間が正直ない…場面が多かった、ここまで
大学卒業してこの夏まで４・５・６・７月かなこの4か月間なかなかこうね常になにかしらしなきゃいけないという状態が続いてて
あの、ご存じのとおり東京に行くこともめちゃくちゃ増えまして、東京にも家をかまえることによって、この静岡の部屋と東京の部屋の両方を管理しなきゃいけない
掃除も含めてね、掃除もあるし洗濯もあるしまぁ、その他もろもろの管理とかも色々あって
ぶっちゃけもうね、一人だと無理だと思った時があったんですよ
結構ね、てかムリ！！
まぁ、そこが手伝ってくれるヤツが一人家にいてまぁ、掃除とかね洗濯、あと実は今編集とかもちょっと手伝ってもらおうと思ってたりしてて
色々な場面でかなりのサポートを受けさせてもらうことができそうなのでボク的にはすごいありがたいお話でございます
いつか何とかしようとおもってたずっと、ずっと思ってたんですけど
やっぱバタバタしててタイミングがなくてメインチャンネルも手を抜きたくないし、
かといって、東京に行かないわけにもいかないんで
まぁ、無理するしかなかったんですけども、なんかこの8月からはね
ひとまず少し、僕の荷が軽くなりそうな気がしております。
これによって、ちょっとメインチャンネルももっとこうなんかやりたいことがどんどんできればいいなと思ってるんですけども
ひとまず、ほんとに大事なお知らせというか、僕ん家には必ず弟がいるっていう話になります。
助かるよ、実際
なんかそういうのマサキがいるからいいじゃんって思うかもしれないんですけど
あいつも基本学生なんで、勉強するのが基本なんで
毎日動画手伝ったり洗濯とか掃除やらせるわけにもいかないんで
ホントに部屋が汚いってよくみんなに言われるんですけど掃除する暇もなく東京にいくこととかが結構あって
ほんとに時間がなかった
昨日も実は夜中ずっと部屋の掃除をしてて大分部屋は綺麗になったので
というわけでおまえらぁ！！8月は…盛り上がる月になりそうだな！！！
といわけで夏本番ですがこれからもはじめしゃちょーをよろしくお願いします。
なんかちょっと悪戯してやろ…